I gotta ask you how happy is the
aluminum foil industry with the song
coil do you actually hear from them you
know I did oddly and I full disclosure I
got a big box of free aluminum foil from
like Reynolds Wrap like the week after
that song came out right so so I'm
thinking my next song should be about
like a big pile of money I'll get a big
rock like from like the federal reverb
yeah for endorsing our product yeah
you're getting the wrong freebies with
foil you are the king of the costume
change I don't know if everyone realizes
how many costume changes you go through
in a show but you've probably set the
record haven't you I I'm told it's three
more than Lady gaga
I don't know if that's true or not but
it we need dozen or so my show pretty
more than Lady gaga yeah you gotta get
your doctor Star Wars Star Wars Jedi
robes and your amish outfit and your
Nirvana and Devo suits and the fat food
of course it's about the fat suit the
fat suit one of your most famous suits
of all time from the phat video I
believe we have a photo of it
that's either that's either the costumer
you during a very depressing time in
your life and so I'm curious
what's it like performing in that suit
because as I said earlier I've had this
this experience a night of putting on a
suit and that's a pain in the ass well
you know that that suit oddly not saved
my life on a couple occasions because I
fallen off the stage off the front of
stage of two times over the years and
both times I was wearing the fat suit
and I took out the first few rows of
fans but I was fine you were just you
were just lying there lolling around and
people had to pick you up yeah how
humiliating
you know I've I want to mention this
because I think there's a lot of young
people watching it's you've never ever
ever touched drugs your name is Weird Al
Yankovic but that's net was never your
thing and when you were a kid though you
were happy when other people were maybe
trying something you thought that helped
your comedy yeah you know I never took
drugs because I figured that would make
me act you know normal right and I
didn't want to go there but ya know I
actually liked being around stoned
people like in college my roommate was
uh you know stoned a lot and I liked
being around him cuz it was easy to make
him laugh it didn't take much it's a
hard way to test a joke on a guy who
stoned
Hey look at my hand then you try it in a
club that chilled chilled with Chad what
happened here I'd loved it now you are
performing at the Hollywood Bowl this
weekend this is a big dream for you it
is I mean you know that's an iconic it's
iconic like the people that play there
the Beatles
Hoobastank
what goes on yeah and it's you know it's
special for me because the very first
concert I ever saw was at the Hollywood
Bowl my mom took me there when I was
like 6 years old who wrote it bus and
saw this wonderful magical evening of
classical music on the bullet at the
Bowl and uh you know if I could go back
in time and and tell the the
six-year-old me that one day I would be
there on stage performing with a
Hollywood Bowl orchestra I probably
would have said yeah that sounds about
right two years no not two years we'll
catch Weird Al Yankovic on his mandatory
world tour including two special
performances tomorrow and Saturday at
the Hollywood Bowl congratulations all
that see all of his tour dates at Weird
Al calm so cool to have you setup
[Applause]
you